[Music]  presidential candidate Mitt Romney has  come under fire for his tax plan critics  are saying it with lower taxes on the  rich while raising taxes on the middle  class now yesterday Romney appeared on  CNN to defend himself sort of set the  record straight I don't think he did the  best job polls showed that a majority of  the public believes right now that you  not that you should not allow for the  extension of the tax cuts for the  wealthy people at the top end of the  scale do you agree with the  characterization that it would be  reckless all right look I know that very  wealthy you're gonna do just fine if I'm  elected that's the group of people that  I'm most concerned about they need our  and the poor if you're poor I give you  back I give you nothing on that I have a  787 billion dollars  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  that's my laughing mommy